Sometimes things are simpler
A source of important ideas
Which radically changes the world
A few years ago, my husband was "Nishant" (co-founder)
He lives and travels in China for a few months
He had many difficulties when trying to order vegetarian food
Therefore, learning Chinese was necessary for him
The problem faced by "Nishant"
Showed the magnitude of problems faced by language learners around the world
So we thought about creating an application
Easy to access and low cost
And effective language teaching
Almost 80% of the population of India belongs to productive age groups
They can get jobs, but they do not succeed
Because of their lack of proficiency in English
Therefore English proficiency is necessary for them
To change their lives
My name is "friend of mine"
I am from Mumbai
After my retirement, I decided to do something useful
So I joined Hello English
Many children around us
They want to learn English
Joining Hello English has given me enough confidence
To go to my towns and educate the poor and the needy
this is my goal
I am in Kochi for that
Much improved in English
Before that, I was afraid to speak English in front of others
But I have overcome my fears now
welcome
how are you?
what's your name?
Bogar
Wonderful.
My name is Sidhar
this is good
Hi
What do you mean hi?
Namaste
English is useful for higher education
And open up better areas of life
good
Wonderful
At first, we never dreamed that we would achieve such success
There are over 30 million users currently in use
We are larger than any university or school
Have existed for many years in India
Google Play gives us statistics and data
About the behavior of users so that we can access
To a larger base of users
Our inspiration and enthusiasm
Is to hear others talk about
The effectiveness of learning English using the application
Have benefited greatly from this
This gives us greater strength to continue
And strive to make a greater impact
I believe that what man gives to the world in his own eyes
He will be punished in the Hereafter
So I will try to provide my best.